as a person is going into the final year
of the physics degree at the University
of Oxford I've done quite a lot of study
in my time and I believe that if you
want to study the most effective you
should follow five simple rules rule
number one realize that learning is
individual there's this stereotype of
studying taking place in complete
silence in a library and that somehow if
you're not studying like that then
you're doing it wrong but the thing to
realize is that there is no such thing
as the wrong way to study if you work in
a particular way and find that it works
for you then you're doing it right
education comes from the Latin Educare a
meaning to draw forth and that's exactly
what studying is all about it's not
about stuffing your head full of facts
it is about making the most of your
potential and in order to do that you
have to tailor your studying I
personally work at my best in a library
in silence with earplugs in but then
sometimes I don't sometimes I've worked
better in an environment like a coffee
shop or my college common room where
there's the sound of other people
buzzing around you if you don't know
what works best for you then experiment
try working in different environments
and try working with music without music
with friends on your own once you find a
way that works for you stick with it
think about where you work at your best
so bedroom coffee shop library wherever
but also when you work at your best
again personally I prefer to work on new
material in theory in the morning and
then practice in the afternoon but that
varies from subject to subject again
experiment and see what works best for
you
rule number 2 managing your time this is
absolutely crucial managing your time is
all about making the job of studying as
easy as possible for you so if you don't
do it you're only making life harder for
yourself than you need to
when I say managing your time I mean on
two different timescales both on a daily
basis but also on a longer time scale of
terms and months on a daily basis plan
what you're going to do each day every
evening I'll write a to-do list of what
I want to accomplish tomorrow so that
would be things like do this problem
sheet finish this section notes whatever
and in doing that I'm trying to time
table about eight hours worth of work
and that's a good amount to aim for
every day in the long run in the couple
of weeks leading up to exams you're
probably gonna want to allow for a
couple more hours per day planning your
time so your revisit material is
absolutely crucial what I do is keep a
diary of work and then at the end of
each day write down what it was that
I've done that day then turn ahead one
week and write down a reminder to review
what I just done and then the same thing
for one month's time by writing in your
day's work you keep track of what you've
done and it allows you to look at it
tomorrow and see what you need to review
and you can incorporate that and you
were to do this for the next day if
you're consistent with it it becomes a
very powerful tool another tool that
people find really useful is using a
whiteboard and I use this a lot in the
past to keep track of deadlines so
whenever I'll set a problem sheet an
essay or an assignment whatever I would
write in on the whiteboard when I was
given it what I had to do and when it
was due in then put that in a visible
place and make sure that you check it
every day so you can never forget what
it is you have to do you can also use it
to plan ahead the next day's work or do
rough working for a problem sheet on it
in the longer term don't start working
too late you can always start revising
material before you finished everything
in class leaving everything to the last
minute only adds extra stress and means
you're never going to be able to perform
your best in exams sit down with a
calendar or diary and work out how many
weeks you've gotten to your exams then
write a list of all the material we need
to cover by them then decide how you
want to structure your time do you want
to do all the particular subject in one
go one subject at a time or would you
prefer to mix it up doing different
subjects in one day or in one week
personally I prefer the latter
then you need to drop a rough timetable
splitting up the time that's available
to you between the material that you
need to cover make sure that you have a
rough idea of when you want to get
ticking modules done so you can gauge
your progress and know if you're falling
behind schedule also when do you want to
practice personally I find it most
beneficial to do theory behind something
first then a day or so later do some
practice then in the week or a couple of
weeks before the exams get my hands on
as many passed papers as possible and
drill exam technique now some people
prefer to revise purely
pass papers though some personal
experience I wouldn't recommend that I
think it's better to focus on the
material making sure you understand it
first then practicing laws
rule number three manage your notes as I
said before learning is as individual as
people are and so notes that two people
make any two people make will never be
the same but I believe that there are
some basic rules you try and stick to
when making your note the first of those
is to try and keep your notes consistent
this year I probably own a bit OTT on
this and I wrote all of my notes on
exactly the same type of paper with
exactly the same type of pen with the
same color scheme and subheading
structure throughout and yeah that's
pretty bit over the top but keeping your
notes consistent I find helps me
synthesize information that bit better
plus it looks professional another one
of these rules is to realize that
certain subjects lend themselves to
certain types of making notes so physics
for example which involves lots of
richly detailed concepts and absolutely
loads of mathematical sections I
personally found it best to produce
notes which read like a textbook so I
even had a page numbering system and a
contents page so I could use it as a
reference and those notes those final
notes represent the culmination of notes
from textbooks notes from lectures and
notes from tutorials
however for something like anthropology
or geography which involves lots of
concepts with absolutely loads of case
studies and references it might be more
useful to produce something like an a3
mind map which links information
spatially to a concept also remember
that there are different types of notes
those two examples I've already given
textbook notes and mind maps are
examples of visual learning the idea
being that you look at the information
on the page and you remember it but just
as validly you could produce notes which
appeal to other stars of learning so
learning by hearing auditory learning
and learning by doing
kinesthetic learning examples of these
might be making recordings or videos of
yourself explaining concepts and then
playing them back as a revision or the
classroom classic is to imagine yourself
as an electron and then
think about how changing the voltage or
resistance of the circuit might change
the way that you move and remember that
you can always mix up different styles
and notes you can always do some visual
notes and some kinesthetic notes if that
will help you broadly speaking though
try and keep your notes whatever they
may be as consistent as you can and also
as clean and uncluttered as you can my
notes have loads of white space on the
page and they're written as clearly as I
can manage any clutter on the page is
only making your brain work harder than
absolutely has to and give it a break
rule number four take good care of
yourself yes I am gonna make this point
yes I know it is really boring but it is
so important you're never going to be
able to perform at your best if you are
not at your best so yeah do all those
things that your parents and teachers
have been telling you to do for years
try and get a good amount of sleep each
night if you if you can improv out eight
hours if you don't then your brains only
going to be tired and you won't be able
to take in new information or remember
old information try to exercise two or
three times a week go swimming go
running play some football go to the gym
whatever as well as making you fitter
exercise releases and dolphins which are
the body's feel-good chemicals and so it
will make you happier and better able to
study and also if you're something other
than just working to look forward to
especially if you take your exercise
with a friend like going running with a
friends a great idea probably the most
important thing though is to
consistently eat a good diet and when I
say that I don't just mean eat salad I
mean eat a balanced diet with plenty of
protein fish if you can enough calories
not too many sugary things there's a
tendency amongst people to few late
night study sessions sometimes all study
sessions with sugary foods to give you a
buzz and a sugar high and yeah you're
going to get a sugar high for a bit but
the low it comes after that it's just
going to make you want to give up
studying for the night also a UCLA study
recently showed that a diet high in
sugar significantly hampers the brain's
ability to synthesize new information
and recall old information and this
isn't to say that you shouldn't eat any
sugary foods just try and cut down where
you can it's the small changes that
make a big difference like drinking diet
soft drinks instead of regular ones or
stead of having chocolate as a snack
having nuts also drink plenty of water
it's a really common problem to get
dehydrated while studying so keep a
bottle of water close to hand and keep
drinking throughout the day rule number
five work really hard I've saved this
point to last because if I'd mentioned
at any earlier it's would have put
people off but also because it is the
most important point to make none of
what I've said before is going to count
for anything
if you're not willing to put the hard
work in the only way that anyone's ever
done anything ever is by putting in lots
and lots of hard work the whole genius
being 1% inspiration 99% perspiration
quote is true even Einstein one of the
most intelligent scientists that ever
lived took ten years to form his theory
of general relativity and the theory is
a triumph it's one of those incredible
accomplishments that humankind has ever
managed but if he hadn't sat down and
thought about it for ten years put in
the hours of doing really really hard
maths we wouldn't have a theory of
relativity if you want to succeed the
only way to do it is to sit down and get
on with it to put in the hours of work
to put in the blood sweat and tears but
hard work in itself does not guarantee
success ultimately it's not about what
you put into your studying that counts
is about what you get out of your study
that counts and that's exactly where all
stuff I talked about previously comes in
if you're willing to put in those hours
of effort the dozens of hours of sitting
down and doing hard work then you need
to make sure that what you put in counts
if you're going to work hard make sure
that your learning is tailored to you
manage your time and manage your notes
and take good care of yourself if you do
all those things then the work that you
appear in is going to be worth so much
more best of luck